hi I'm Kristen I'm a professor for an
online master's degree in chemistry and
biochemistry but some days I really miss
teaching undergraduates ochem so welcome
to my classroom educate ability is my
effort to make organic chemistry more
accessible for you
okay there's a really challenging
subject we need to visualize
three-dimensional structures in our mind
but then we need to draw those in two
dimensions on paper to produce work for
exams and things like that we also need
to recognize electron density hot spots
on one part of the molecule and how
those might interact with a
electronically cold spot on another
molecule to form a chemical bond we also
need to be able to show that process by
drawing curved arrows that show where
the electrons are moving organic
chemistry is extremely visual so I'll
use a variety of media to help convey
these challenging topics we'll use
handheld models computer generated
models and molecular animation so you
can see where the bonds are breaking and
forming I hope that through my videos
you're able to gain an understanding of
reactivity so you don't just need to
memorize every reaction mechanism which
is so hard you can actually go through
and be like this is my electron hot spot
and my arrow has to come from there once
you can do that and gain that ability
organic chemistry can be really
satisfying it becomes like a logic
puzzle and it can actually be fun I hope
to share some of my enjoyment for
organic chemistry with you thanks for
watching
you